Alright. We're in San Jose. I mean, we're going to do the intro private,
that donor thing, right?
All right. I never read fucking donuts.
What everybody was telling me a hundred this place was
try to go and get one of the smaller ones
like Brookville maple. All right, let's see here.
Oh my God. Fucking delicious.
Steroids, donuts.
So where in the downtown? In the downtown area of San Jose.
This is an area that a lot of people make fun of,
especially comedians because we come here, we don't know shit about San Jose.
We don't understand that this nicer areas.
There's all these great places to eat.
I'm going to try to show you some of them.
There's another one of those ugly apartment buildings that I see in every single
city. Now, man, that looks like some fucking eastern European shit.
Did that plane landed right there? Alaskan Airlines.
This is what's fucked up about San Jose's airport. Granted,
I don't know shit about aviation. I don't get, they have,
they have two runways. Usually they got one. One goes this way.
The other goes that way through the wind. You know. If the wind shifts,
you have options to take off. They have,
they have to two runways like parallel to each other,
like literally the exact same numbers,
like whatever's 23 and whatever the fuck that would be 23 moneys fucking 18
would be five 23 and five right. Whatever the fuck they are.
So I would think that,
I'm going to ask an instructor the question about that. Like, so what if the,
uh, what if the wind is coming too far? Why is it, I can't remember.
That's the funny thing about when you get your pilot's license,
the amount of Shit you forget is ridiculous. When you're in ground school,
you're on it, you know, whatever you think fucking meets.
Then after a while it's just like driving the car.
I can't 10 and two was it three and six? I don't know.
Just imagine thinking that shit except you're up there.
I just felt like Don Rickles said casino,
you know better than you know up there. I love that Uber, it,
that Vaudevillian background he had that he had to go like that. Like,
we didn't know what up there was by the way. Great outtakes in that building.
All right. This is the part of the cities that I liked.
You know you got auto body stuff over there.
You got a little restaurant over here.
This is the parts of the cities that I like where it's sort of industrial.
You can also, you know,
go get something to eat or maybe go play some drums.
Maybe there's a studio around there. Can you imagine that?
If Paul freckles got to play the drums for a minute.
Oh
Andrew, I teed you up for that cut t job for it
right here. We've got some railroad tracks.
Nobody takes the fucking train anymore. You know,
I'm always amazed at the lack of security again on a train.
Like if I was in Isis, like that's how I would get in.
I'd get on a train the airport, they check for everything. You get on a train.
You could literally have a box that said TNT, you know, I'll let you get on. Oh,
here's where the San Jose fucking shirts.
It's the shit.
They made it to the conference they made to the [inaudible] Cup finals last
year. So they got one more hurdle after all those years.
I used to always say San Jose sharks sharks were basically the San Diego charges
on skates cause they always fuck their fans over.
They have a great regular season and then they kicked shit the bed when it comes
to playoffs. But these, these aren't, these aren't your uncle's San Jose sharks.
I can't even say your grandfathers because they've been around so little.
Oh look at it's wells Fargo. Can you imagine? Look, they have one up here.
It's unbelievable. It's almost like we're down to just three different bags.
So now we're in the downtown San Jose area.
Bicycles that you can rent.
I can never get those fucking things out of there.
I could just put the money in. It never works.
And I start fucking the fucking crazy shit. You know,
I was always some woman and when it's like some Hillary Clinton fucking
pantsuits staring at me waiting to get her bicycle,
of course she can figure it out, right? Cause she's relaxed.
I took a yoga class. I had a facial.
You like how I blame her in that story rather than the fact that I'm a complete
psycho.
Why don't I ask the Hillary Clinton dress lady for a little bit of help?
I could do that. Oh look, it's chase. Jesus Christ. Can you imagine that?
It's almost as if we're down to two or three bags. What's left?
What's the one Sam Jackson does? What's in your wallet? Capital one.
Capital one. I like when he says what's in your wallet? I don't know Sam.
I know what's in your wallet.
A bunch of fucking cash they show that got their commercial be 20 seconds.
You know what good for him. Good for him.
He's probably not making any money off of pulp fiction at this point.
The way they adjust it down, you know,
after like the third showing on t and t probably gets checks for like a dollar
48. What I love about northern or mid California.
A lot of these, you know, smaller cities, even though it isn't exactly small,
is uh, you know, as much as they have the skyscrapers and stuff,
you see a lot of the sort of like a lot of the original buildings,
what it looked like, you know, during that period where it was just like,
you know,
White Europeans and Latinos, you know,
all like facing off. I kind of meeting at a dog park, right.
Sniffing each other's asses, seeing what's going to go down. Right.
And then they just fucking go at it. Can I turn here? This is one thing.
I can't turn it no problem. That's where the guy got shot.
I'm going to drive by that right with here.
Somebody literally got shot and killed right in front of the Improv.
They weren't at the show,
they just happened to be walking by and I felt bad because they took a picture
of the dead body under the sheet and it was right underneath the marquee and
then the name of the comedian was, was on the mark. He
was like, he wasn't at his show. He's just walking by.
Look at this soulless fucking place here.
I don't know if you can go right on red. That's just a cop.
I'm so destined to get a ticket. Every time I go to make a fucking move,
there's a cop right there. Look at that place.
That's when you're going in there for the meeting and you got those people you
ride down on the elevator and they all have like their name tags on it.
Something. I always feel bad from you cause it's always,
I superimpose what I want under other people. Maybe they're happy.
Everybody all like wearing the same colored fucking izod.
You went down there to figure it to strategize on the next daughter.
Does that help deaf people that fucking sang. If I was deaf I would. Oh,
am I blind? I was gonna say,
I don't think that'd be like darts going by my head.
Well that helps blind people. Sorry, I'm fucking idiot.
Why are you watching this? Because it makes you feel better about yourself,
doesn't it? Yeah. Typical, typical. Do say something negative on Twitter now,
Huh? Does that fill you up? Does that feel like a hug from your dad?
And what's funny about San Jose,
it's this like nobody here a lot of the times and they got this fucking train
that goes up and down and there's just like nobody on it. If you get on it,
you're going to feel like you're in Jacob's ladder. You'd be like,
did I get killed in Vietnam? Where is everybody?
It's always some old bag ladies staring at you for a head start spinning around.
No train truck. And there's always somebody yelling out here. You hear that?
And it's either a crazy homeless person. You know what yelling I like,
I like when you go into a Sushi restaurant and all the guys yell at you when you
come walking in. I always feel like I'm in like Japanese cheers.
And I'm like, norm makes you feel welcome. So anyways,
I've been doing a bunch of shows out here trying to get my new hour together.
And uh, this is one of my, like this Improv here in San Jose is great.
It's old. It has a history, you know? Of course.
All the places have history though. It was built in like 19 oh something.
Harry Houdini played here,
a Charlie Chaplin Fatty Arbuckle,
all fatty and now me right there.
Craig Proops is in a couple of weeks. Marlon Wayans two great acts.
You should check out right about where that wet spot is.
That's right where the person got killed or bastard and then they just had the
marquee.
I felt so bad for the comic. It's just like, dude, did I need that shit? I mean,
it's hard enough to sell tickets after what the bank is did in 2008 you've got
to show a dead book. There was no reason to show the Improv name.
I know what it was was the photographer was getting a little antsy,
but it's what say a, it's basically a theater.
It's one of those ones that was when it was made,
was made like I think rebuilt after it burned down in the 19 hundreds and like
Harry Houdini was there. Charlie Chapter
[inaudible].
Well. Yeah, fatty Arbuckle is back when you,
your nickname was just what you were, you know, fatty Arbuckle.
You could never call him that. No. What the fuck would they call them?
Probably calling his real name. Like Todd
[inaudible].
Carbuncle everybody, it's kind of fat, isn't it?
Don't say that it hurt his feelings.
Yeah.
Um, I don't know. If you listen to my podcast, I fucking hate museums.
I respect them. I respect all the smart people that go in there and like, Ooh,
look at that fork that somebody used with Julius Caesar was still an office.
I'm just not into it.
They have here arguably the most boring museum you could ever have.
It's a museum. The Museum of Technology. I can't,
I mean, I didn't hate museums so much. I go in there,
I just can't imagine what they would have. All right. So evidently,
okay.
The, the, the best part of the museum is the gift shop. Just
what would you get? I mean,
I just feel you're gonna walk in there and they're just gonna have like,
you know like they have like, you know,
whatever the fuck we were tadpoles all the way to be in men.
They probably have that with like calculators and everything.
But I felt all right, here it is.
Here it is right there and Museum of technology.
If you ever wanted to see the history in a laptop, there it is.
I actually respect that on some level. You know what I mean?
I just don't get a thrill out of that stuff. So as usual, if I don't like it,
I should all over it because of childhood. You see that now?
You know what it's like for my wife to watch TV with me.
Can't you just stop talking and just sit here and enjoy things with me?
Why do you have to make fun of everything? I Dunno cause it paid for the house.
I hate that one. Alright, now we're going to take a break from the tour.
We're going to go get some tacos spread like red, like sorry.
We're going to get some tacos.
See what happens when you try to make the word Taco funny.
Now over the Stop Line here, you know this, this is, is it the end of the month?
It's the end of the month. That's when the Dudley do, right?
Fucking cop comes up like actually free freemiums over the fucking [inaudible]
and that's when you think about taking his gun kitty.
I look at that all gold building man and minds me of the radio station Vic Vic
Reynolds works at and F is for family,
which by the way is coming out the end of May for season two.
I just scared this lady. Sorry.
All right, here we go. All right, we're going to go to the original Joe's.
The weirdest name for Italian restaurant can be original Luis, right?
Oh fuck you was. Nothing drives me up the fucking wall.
Jesus Christ in one way. This is one way.
Where are your wipers on this? It's all in one.
Very efficient.
All right, so listen to this on my podcast.
You know that I fucked up my shoulder. I rotated cuff.
I've got like a pitcher's injury and I have no athletic abilities whatsoever.
And uh, sorry I was trying to work. Right. Um,
so I was trying to describe the exercise that somebody showed me that's really
been helping me since this role,
you hold fucks out there like me can't afford any physical therapy cause you
don't have health insurance, right? So here's the deal.
This is what you start with. You just like stir the paint, right?
You just like this, right? Like you stare in small circles. It's like this.
Everybody's looking at me like what?
And then you just get right to the threshold of pain. Right fucking there
and then you just go the other way. Same thing. Just do that for like,
I don't know, 30 seconds till it feels warmed up.
And then this is the exercise here, right? Cause you know rotator cuff,
it's that first 30 degrees. You're like ah fuck it. Just use the,
use your fingers here to take most of the weight of your arm and you just walk
it up like this slowly cause this is where your fucking hurts.
You just walk it up the wall like that. I you
motherfucker and you get it all the way up here. You could stretch like that.
You walk up the lady, then I just do this. Inchworm my way down.
You do a set of three to five. Oh, you fucking cunt. Ah,
you see it works. You do a set of three to five.
Um, and it's improved my own bias. I, it feels like it's like an 80%,
although I just did those kinds of quickly,
so I probably just fucked it up again.
All right, so now we're heading up to uh, whatever the fuck it is.
Santana something around the boulevard or Santana city. I don't know what it is.
This is where all the money is. All that silicone valley, all the shit that,
that, that you use the iPhone to the fucking robot you can have sex with.
This is where it gets made and we're going to go out there,
see what these people look like, see where they shop. They don't see biggie.
You know, that's one thing about those nerds that read them. Like,
just like wait for thin or just absolutely fed flux.
Everybody processes stress differently. All right, here we are Westfield Mall,
but the same old fucking stores that it may seize.
Probably a cheesecake factory that you gotta have champs scores.
The store someplace to get frozen yogurt, right?
Let a bunch of moms walking around trying to look fuckable competing with the
daughters. That's a big, that's a big mall thing.
Now we know that for 21 mentality. You're not,
you're 51 all right, 51 covered up. Okay sweetheart, it's over.
No one's looking at me. You had your time. Be like a retired athlete.
Just sit around and talk about the glory days that you suck in Dick back in the
70s so
sure.
Alright, well we're going to see some Gretchen was you look,
look it right there. It's a chase bag next to holy shit.
Next to a bank of America.
So we have at least three banks and then the one Sam Jackson does.
What's in your wallet
is another one. Macy's. That's what? Cheese cake factory. I called it,
I called it. Sorry. Fucking took out your card,
crate and barrel.
This is why I like the downtown area.
They had all this fucking privately owned owned at these restaurants,
like people travel and they get excited. Oh, they have a cheesecake factory.
They go in and they order what the fuck they could have ordered right down the
street from their fucking house. I just feel like for me,
traveling is trying different things. Sorry,
my wife and watching all this fucking reality and that's all they say on it.
Everything gets so about them. They just go free me. I just feel like for me,
when I saw those starving children, I thought, you know, it's bad.
It's bad as it is. I would love to have that waistline.
Do you know what he mean? Oh, here we go. Here's all the high end stores.
This is where the nerds all shop. Tesla,
Gucci to me, Tesla,
he go nearby car. Oh yeah, the wallet chain.
Wall chain, man.
This has to be one of the most solace places I've ever been to in my life.
Why is it so bad?
You can tell even like the way that trees are, you can just tell, you know,
they just stuck it there. Okay. Right there.
That's where a bunch of people are making a bunch of money. You know,
all the nerds in there creating apps at the Splunk.
It say you had to just app,
do you want to like track your chips and like see how much protein is in it?
You're like conscious steps and uh,
the amount of Scarlet's that's coming out of your Dick. It's use millennials.
Love it. All right. Yes. That is why they all go to see movies out here.
All the nerds, you know, maybe that's a movie Hap, I dunno,
this is a, I'm going to do, you know,
I'm going to try to do it because I've been really negative up until this point.
I'm going to, I'm going to be,
I'm going to go down to Santana row and read nothing but positive. Okay.
I just facetime with my wife and she was like, oh, it looks fine.
So maybe it's me. I think of that up there. Look for that fits into that.
I mean, even though it was built two seconds ago,
they've literally just finished putting that paint up there.
It does look vaguely like European, doesn't it? Come on,
let's go for a walk.
This is literally one of these places. Thank God there's like nobody here.
I came here on the weekend. I would probably spontaneously just start crying.
Oh my God. What? I love this place right here.
So look down. Go. I like this place for kitchen shit. It means on the table.
It's like my joke from a HBO special, right? Put it on the table.
Would it filming something? Jesus fucking Christ. How are you sir?
Did you come out yet? All right, thank you. No worries. No worries.
Any interrupting and seated mean to diesel. People still wear that. Oh my God.
The flicks though. Nineties they were the ones that fucked up the whole jeans.
Everybody's jeans back in the day. Could were fucking Levi's dad jeans.
Nobody gave a fuck. They were like 30 bucks.
Considered American classics. This is what they're going for out here.
That's the look, you know, stay on 600 yards.
Stare at it. Fucking, she's kicked factory over the horizon. Okay.
The one positive thing that I will say about Santana row is it doesn't go on
forever. It's only a couple of blocks and then it's over
35 zero to 62.5 seconds.
That's like motorcycle fast. Let's be honest.
This is the only thing that I can't deal with here is this giant.
Do you guys make something where you can just pull this down where I don't have
to look at this the whole time. It's really distracting. Huh?
What year were you born? Yeah. So you guys grew up in this.
You're going in 1994. You're going to be one that's 23 this year.
That's Friday. Fuck, I'm old. She's as priced.
It was 26. Well, um,
no, that is insane.
But I mean I could easily have something,
I can just buy some cardboard and I could just put, cause I don't need this,
right. I just, I shouldn't use climate control radio
because it helps with navigation that the,
what do I look out that's my navigation?
Like driving down the road like this can this thing drive itself? Yeah,
they have software still calibrating those. Is it like,
just like a button you can push to? That's so amazing.
So like if I went out and got hammered, I don't need to call Uber. Right.
I just press a button and I, I just pass. I'm still liable. Yeah,
but Tesla's not liable. Well, how are you going to prove that I was drunk?
We will show the backseat.
No, but I've learned you run away from the accident.
That's what this guy did for me. All right,
cool. All right. There you go.
That was awesome. That was incredible.
Zero to 62.5 seconds. I don't know that that's,
that's the way the world's going to go yet. Has to go electric.
The gas combustion engine can't compete with that.
I'm just going to miss that sound. You know what,
there's probably going to be an app on a car in the future to make the sound of
like a fucking an old school, you know,
muscle car engine. But, uh, all right. So the guy said,
I don't know if we have that in the video, but it was
140,000 bucks to get the top of the line. He said it was all about the battery.
I didn't get what he was saying, whatever,
140 grand to go to 0.5 seconds to zero to 60
other than that, it just looks like a piece of shit. Nissan Maxima.
That's what I can't get past. But it's a four door sedan.
I wonder after you put all the people in it, you know,
for people after they ate some burgers, if it goes up, I mean, it is way right?
I don't know. That was worth the trip over here.